Marvel fans have come up with an
absolutely crazy theory about Captain
America AKA Steve Rogers that will blow
your mind at the end of Avengers end
game Steve was tasked with returning the
Infinity Stones to their respective
timelines but he didn't come back when
he was supposed to instead he stayed in
the 1940s to be with his one true love
Peggy Carter this Theory suggests that
when Steve stayed back with Peggy he
didn't just sit around the house instead
he changed his name to Fred and started
an educational children's television
show called Mr Rogers Neighborhood
that's right Captain America is Mr
Rogers this theory is pretty believable
because we know how good-natured Steve
Rogers is and we know how willing he is
to help people in need Steve held grief
counseling sessions following the snap
and Avengers end game using his years of
wisdom to help give people Clarity and
closure in their lives this just shows
how Steve wanted to help spread
positivity and to change people's lives
for the better just as Mr Rogers did
with his television show